girls you have been expressing your ix
about guys for clout on social media for
about a year now so if i'm not allowed
to make up a hypothetical situation with
a hypothetical 10 out of 10 you are not
allowed to rile together your female
community to talk about x
james smith welcome to the show hey it's
good to be back it's been a bit of a
long stint since i've been on it feels
like i was on a couple months ago but
it's been nearly a year it's been a long
time yeah what's going on i'm a
different man why i'm completely
different
look at this setup
for a start we were just talking about
this offline
last time i'm embarrassed of the version
of myself a year ago
technologically
in many ways professionally
technologically personally like
last time we did this talk i was wearing
a broadcaster headset which at the time
i thought was innovative podcasting i
was like i've got a mic got headphones
connected
now
a sure sm7b the pinnacle of podcasting
microphones i've got three of them in it
right
a dslr which you know i never fully
appreciated the power of podcast clips
an hour ago the game has changed yes sir
well you how long have you had in uh
tick tock now
i've had it for two years but i've only
started respecting it as a platform
probably six months and you've got how
many followers
1.5 million
out of nowhere
i did 580 000 in a week
what was that due to what did you talk
about
there was one uh video that really
booted off which is a subject i've
actually spoken about for years so when
i did the video on it it kind of reeled
off the tongue which is the swimmer's
body illusion where
i don't ever say this to [ __ ] on fitness
people but
i'd say to people in the video look
imagine there's a person who wants to
get in shape and they look at different
physiques they want to
you know
idealize and they go oh i would be a
runner but then i'd probably be a bit
skinny and look a bit miserable oh i
could be a bodybuilder but then i might
be a little bit too big and look a bit
thick so then they go oh swimmers i love
a swimmer's physique so i'm gonna start
swimming then three four months pass and
they like realize it's an illusion
swimmers don't always look the way they
look because they swim they swim because
of the way they look similarly to me the
people always go oh it's right for you
you're big and broad and that's why you
you know that's because you play rugby
and i was like no i'm i'm big and broad
so i play rugby when 50 lads in a year
play rugby the big broad dense heavy
guys stay on and enjoy it and the people
that don't don't and
in the gym people that lift weights for
six months and don't build muscle don't
continue the endeavor and they start
picking other sports and there's always
that adage that you don't pick your
sport your sport picks you and
so many people in the fitness industry
there there are people genetically who
have a much easier time getting in good
shape and maintaining good shape and
when they take their tops off on holiday
rather than people going oh you're
empathetic intelligent you care about
people you should be a coach they go wow
you're in great shape you should become
a pt and that's unfortunately the state
of affairs of the fitness industry
largely is
people aren't you know people don't look
the way of what because of what they
preach they preach what they preach
because of the way they look
um yes it's a selection effect and the
people that come out the other side are
the ones that were predisposed to be
good at it in any case i mean that's one
of my friends says that he always wanted
to learn to bench in powerlifting from
the guy that had long arms so i don't
want to learn to bench from the guy with
short arms because it's easy for him i
wouldn't learn a bench from the guy that
had an absolute nightmare in doing it i
wanna learn to deadlift and squat from
the tallest power lifter in the gym
reason being well there's another
argument here that um
if you see two candidates that are of
equivalent um merit equivalent
qualifications equivalent experience and
all the rest of it but one of them is
really ugly and the other one's really
good looking you should hide the really
ugly one because that person has had to
do all of the things the good-looking
person's done and they've had to
overcome the fact that they're ugly as
well
there's also uh
people
your guilty non-guilty verdict isn't
affected but the amount of time you get
sentenced is affected by how good
looking you are so people that are good
looking serve shorter
jail sentences so you just got to make
sure whoever you hire if you do pick the
ugly one that he's not getting locked up
because he's going to be away for a long
time so
you have a lot of female followers and
you've spent many thousands of hours on
the gym floor
do you think that it's acceptable for
guys to look at girls while they're
training
well i suppose if you're all going to
share a room together
to
train
yes but there's i suppose that you've
got the nuance of how long the gaze is
because i'm not sure of this i'm you've
had much smarter people than me on the
podcast but there's probably an
objective measure of when uh an
inquisitive gaze becomes
a gaze with intent and
you know for me i i'm someone that when
i'm in a room i like to read the room in
gym training you know i'm like okay cool
lifting shoes don't need them cool yeah
you know someone using wrist straps when
they're doing decline bench i'm like i'm
trying to figure out my head i'm doing
the math so i'm like my grip assists or
a decline bench
but then sometimes you know i've i'm
someone that talks to someone in the gym
so
uh if i ever see a woman doing like a
hip thrust of significant weight or i
see someone doing mobility work
because i've been in those environments
so i'll often just go up and be like hey
i'm really impressed with what you're
doing here i don't even tell them i'm a
personal trainer i'm just like that
that's a really impressive amount of
weight so you do that you do that as
just another jim schmo walking up to
other people in the gym despite the fact
you're not at work
yeah and i you know for me
if i've ever had to go into a a shopping
center and you know now you have like a
men's floor and a woman's floor i feel
very uncomfortable in what is the
women's area so if i'm over shopping
with my girlfriend and she's like i just
need to get some stuff from here i'm
kind of on edge and if someone would
just speak to me or someone go hey
you're right here by the way yeah yeah
good thanks you know something like that
can really put your your nerves at ease
and for me i suppose it's a bit easier
because i'm a pc i can say look if if i
was caught staring this was a
professional you know it's a
professional stare
this this i'm just making sure your
technique was good but i think that you
know it it's because the gym is
perceived in a hostile environment that
things like a gaze can be taken the
wrong way i suppose context is
everything but being a being a man you
have to be very
you know aware that
if you're in a in a gym environment or a
training environment you don't want to
make people feel uncomfortable
especially if there's a chance they
already feel uncomfortable
i agree there was a video that went
viral on tick tock which you might have
seen about a month and a half ago of a
girl wearing booty shorts and taking a
top off and filming it then she turned
around and called one of the coaches of
pervert did you see that
yeah
it's annoying with stuff like this
because i
i appreciate what people are doing and
this is have you ever noticed that life
at the moment you're never sure if
someone's filming it
like something can happen now
because content is
king and people are spending more time
than ever on their phones like
say someone has like a seizure in a busy
shopping center there's a part of me
that's like
is this a tick tock and that that's a
scary realization to be like and you've
got this bystander effect already as it
is like people not really wanting to get
involved and
it's hard to know if things are now set
up so you see a girl do that in the gym
where you might go over and be like
excuse me you know what's going on here
it's just someone trying to get some
virality on tiktok or social media
but
i think men have an obligation to be
polite you know chivalry is something
that you can barely have a discussion
with anymore
where you know people are right okay so
uh because i'm a woman men are just
gonna objectify me by looking at me
that's not really the discussion to be
had and if i was to catch a dude staring
in the gym i probably like hey mate come
on she's trying to train
relax
i get that man i think both sides are
pretty hyper sensitive there's
definitely an argument to be made as far
as i can see
that
guys need to understand that girls might
feel objectified girls might feel
very sensitive about guys looking for
too long but that video in particular so
there's this girl in booty shorts and
she's taking a long sleeve top off and
there's a sports brush she's already in
like booty shorts takes it off and
there's a sports bra underneath and two
guys
30 yards away in the back of the gym
turning and look as she's taking her
literally as she's de-clothing uh and
she turns around and says can i help you
or what what do you want or something
like that she's zero to a thousand in no
time at all and in the same way that
guys need to understand that girls don't
want to be objectified girls need to
understand that guys are biologically
hardwired to look if something like that
is happening i mean if a guy took his
top off in the middle of the gym some
people would turn around and look
i was just about to say have you ever
heard of a pump cover
no what's that
so like uh bodybuilders uh i've i've
done this but i wasn't steroids before
it's quite almost embarrassing so let's
say you're in the middle of a steroid
cycle you're pretty swell right you get
like a stringy bit stringy vest on
underneath
and say you ate 10 weeks into a cycle
you're pretty juicy so what you do is
you put a massive oversized hoodie on
and track pants
you go into the gym you do your first
four or five sets on a bench like to the
point where you're literally getting so
hot and you're just maxing out the reps
and underneath you know you're a little
bit sweaty you've got a savage pump you
feel like your chest and arms are about
to explode and then you wait until
everyone's in in the gym people are away
from like the water fountains and you
uncover your top because everyone just
thought you were just some big dude and
a baggy jumper then they see the
swolenormus lord swaldemor there and
then you do it so you get the stairs
sebum uh canadian bodybuilder he's
famous for this is that when he takes
his pump cover off and everyone's like
oh my god it's like a gorilla coming in
to you know create alpha status but the
thing is the male bodybuilding community
they like to sneak in under the radar
they don't want the red carpet to be
when they walk into the gym they want it
for when they take their pump cover off
and
there are quite a lot of people in that
setting who kind of cherish the
attention
and again like you know
i wish there was a bit more dialogue in
the gym where if those two guys are
saying she could like can i help you and
i'm sure the majority of times guys oh
sorry you know
ah bad
i don't think people are so ill-intented
or have such poor intentions as people
assume
and
yeah i'm sure a bit of communication and
not going from not to 100 probably be
the
smartest option there yeah well i think
one of the problems we've got at the
moment is that men and women see each
other as adversaries and this is one of
the most
like interesting insights i guess around
gender dynamics at the moment that men
and women have somehow been convinced
that they're playing on different teams
i don't think that men women have been
on different teams pretty much
ever right yeah maybe women didn't have
particular access up until recently
but a lot of the oppression when women
talk about it comes from women like most
slut-shaming comes from women most
pro-life rhetoric so anti-abortion like
anti-pro-choice rhetoric also comes from
women a lot of the um restrictions that
are placed on women come from kind of
without within their own house as
opposed to it being men that are doing
that like men and women have had to
exist together in order to be able to
get families to work in order to have
anything close to a functioning society
for almost forever but now that we want
to try and find tribal groups that we
can jump into whenever we feel is
appropriate
this is just another one gender just
happens to be another one that people
are going to tumble into as well
i love that you've uh brought this topic
up because it is such a topic of
contention i mean if you were to look at
the us political system the left and the
right who heavily oppose each other it's
almost like they've lost sight that the
fact that they're a political party to
run the united states of america to lead
a democracy and a happy nation into the
american dream they've lost all sight of
that instead of the left and the right
being an upward trajectory to support
the political state of the nation
they've become internalized to be
polarized against each other and they're
obviously losing sight of how to run a
country they're just trying to beat
their opposition so
to that merit as well with men and women
at the moment like you say with guys
guys do things to impress other guys if
i shave my chest and increase the volume
of my chest it's because i want to
impress other guys right i don't want to
do it to impress women they don't
appreciate the amount of effort it goes
into to have a chest is about so things
like hairline as well guys are the first
ones to comment on your hairline on tik
tok or whatever like just shave it bro
and you're like
you're you're allowed to have a receding
hairline
i was in croatia a couple weeks ago i
was looking around at europeans
and i was like 75 of every man i can see
here is experiencing some form of hair
loss rather than seeing that as a bad
thing i was like this is more normal
than
we kind of realized and i like watching
older films where nicolas cage for
decades
was a lead actor was hollywood sex icon
with his hairline starting like homer
simpson with three hairs being swept
across bruce willis when he was doing
die hard right and he had gotten 75 bold
and you just had the bits around the
side no okay then so a lot of these
standards and beauty standards like you
say are being upheld by men and the same
with women absolutely like
you know women are less aggressive than
men or especially less physically
aggressive so they are more inclined to
use verbal communication as a way of
being combative with people so
yeah you have that kind of side of
things where gossiping like you say [ __ ]
shaming but the thing is as well that
sometimes there's a lot of double
standards
so this week
uh my friends on the sofa my housemates
have made up a game where they go okay
she's a 10
but she shouts your dad's name when she
orgasms
and like
it was funny like so you would just be
sat there watching tv and then one of
the housemates go she's a 10 but and
you're all like okay here we go
and i put it in a youtube video to break
up what was an informative video and
people like that's disgusting they're
like i was really enjoying that youtube
video until i saw that and the reason
they comment that as well is because
they're trying to change you if they
were truly offended by something they'd
just leave right they'd just be like
this guy's not for me but they're
they're proactively trying to change you
they were calling me a misogynist on all
of these things and i go hold on girls
you have been expressing your ix about
guys
for clout on social media for about a
year now so if i'm not allowed to make
up a hypothetical situation with a
hypothetical 10 out of 10 you are not
allowed to
rile together your female community to
talk about ics there was one that went
viral on tick tock where she was like
i never knew this was my ick but when he
gets in the shower and he kicks the
water to test the temperature
that's my ick if he does that you know
when his shower's warming up and you
give it like those little toe kicks to
check what temperature is and then i was
like girls how can you have this double
standard where you openly express things
that you find explicitly unattractive in
men but the second we make up a
hypothetical situation and we're
oppressive we're misogynistic all of
these things and i'm like come on like
if if we're going to set the standards
as that being a conflict between genders
then [ __ ] how i got featured in a
mega viral ick thread about a year and a
half ago so my one of my many past lives
of being a commercial male model i'd
done some stuff for a nightwear company
like loungeworth nighttime stuff and one
of the icks was a man that wears
matching top and bottom pajamas so you
can imagine like a plaid sort of cross
stripe
scenario like a
what you'd imagine someone in the 1800s
would wear without the cap without that
sort of long like weird fez type thing
and it was me it was the photo was me
and the ick was myself and i was like ah
yeah
at least i don't wear it not properly
but uh yeah you are right i think one of
the reasons that that seems a little bit
more acceptable is that
girls presume that they can say those
things about guys and it's not going to
hurt right that girls are much more uh
how would you say sensitive about their
looks than guys are therefore
the ick threads aren't real like the
she's a 10 but the he's a 10 but i've
seen that put over the top of golden
retriever videos like he's a 10 but he
dances like this when he's waiting for
his food and this golden retriever's
doing a silly dance like i don't think
that it's serious but you are right that
when the
double standards and hypocrisy are what
people love to point out at the moment
in the world and the reason is that it
allows you to have a sense of
righteousness moral righteousness whilst
having done nothing moral to earn it
like you get to point at the failings of
somebody else
and say this is something that shouldn't
happen your your morality stands on the
shoulders of other people now one thing
that i i'm not sure that i would agree
with is that people who comment online
aren't truly offended i think that for a
lot of people that is
by mimesis by seeing what other people
do when they're offended and they say
that they're offended they presume that
that is the way for them to go about
offense that
maybe they're going to leave maybe
they're going to unsubscribe or unfollow
you but first they're going to let you
know why i mean how many comments do you
get that says um absolutely outrageous
unfollowed or absolutely outrageous
unsubscribed like that happens a lot
yeah and i say to people as well i was
like i always like out them a bit i'm
like [ __ ] hell mate this isn't an
airport you don't have to announce your
departure but what's uh
what's kind of interesting as well with
this like kind of
culture that we have now
so i've been devising
kind of a few systems in my mind of why
i think this is now passion is something
that before probably book two i would
have been like go find your passion but
a lot of people came back to me and
they're like
what if i haven't found it and i was
like well yeah it's not something you're
just gonna find on the horizon i
realized i didn't really follow my
passion when i started doing what i do
for work i followed my values
and i didn't even know i was following
my values a lot of the successful
decisions i made were almost by accident
almost baxter so i became a pt because i
just wanted to be happy i thought going
to work in shorts and helping people
would make me happy and it did and i was
like not having to have a boss would
make me happy and it did so i followed
my values it was only four years into
being a pt that i loved my life that i
found passion
so
so many people are disconnected from
their values so many people that they
never ever experience passion and a lot
of people mistake being good at their
job for passion which is another tragic
state statement affairs where they go
yeah i i like my job you know i i hit
bonuses i hit quota i get money and then
when you're infused with enough money
you can use that as a guys to cover up
passion
so there are a lot of people out there
so disconnected from their values that
they never experience experience passion
on the way into a job or during a job
it's now been 10 years of a passionless
existence that they may be covering with
money or they may not be
so when they do
put on their righteous politically
correct hat or they come in from a moral
high ground and they express their
emotions in such a way they feel
something in their belly and not many
people are combative not many people
fight not many people have a martial art
or something they can lean on
so they get this fire in the belly of
self-righteousness and for once they
feel passion and i think a lot of people
are
inspired to be politically correct and
to almost in some respects be a karen
and no disrespect to anyone called karen
because it's the only time in the last
few years they've genuinely felt passion
and for a lot of them i think it's the
only time they've truly felt alive for a
very long time and they get hooked on
that and when you see these like uh do
you see there was a woman who got kicked
off a united a usa flight for screaming
that the guy next to her wouldn't
disclose whether or not he was
vaccinated or not
and in the end it was it was
transatlantic flight
and she's screaming and in the end the
pilot's like get off the plane and i was
like your bag's in the hold you're
flying to the uk you've got you've done
everything
and this is where you decide you're
going to scream and make a big fuss i
reckon she was really enjoying it and
it's a sad state of affairs that that
could be the only time that person's
fire in the belly for months that's the
place that somebody gives themselves a
sense of purpose and righteousness is
when they're actually able yeah well
that that would seem to make sense to me
i think that
it's rare that people love anything very
much
it's quite uncool especially with the uk
background us people might not get this
quite so much because out here is a more
of a collegial
um uplifting optimistic blue sky vision
type uh world whereas the uk is very
much a tall poppy syndrome if you
deviate from the norm people very
quickly will point that out and say why
are you doing that that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's lame that's not gonna work
especially typically i think if you to
take a an average and uh
there was this interesting bit at the
start of eliezer yukowski's book which
is about rationality and he said people
take the piss out of rationalists that
love rationality not because rationality
is a weird thing to love but because so
few people love anything in the modern
world so few people have a genuine
passion about anything in particular so
when you see someone that does they're
an outlier they're such an outlier
because most people are just like what
what is it that you love what do you
love in life beyond family and friends
oh well
uh you know i'm a fan of true crime what
you love true crime like true crime
documentaries that's that's the the
highest point of [ __ ] existence that
you've got true crime or
football team maybe or you know some
sort of sport that they support
those are the sort of places that people
go to and with that vacuum of
meaning and purpose i think that people
do try to fill it with
a stance that gives them the simulacrum
of a sense of meaning
whilst not actually being something that
aligns with how they feel like it's very
performative you know that lady that's
doing that vaccine thing that's super
performative
yeah you're completely right and i i
agree even people like like you say with
sports teams
and what i try and warn a lot of people
of is it's completely fine to love
formula one or love a football team and
even to some people to love your partner
that much but you can't take every part
of currency of happiness and values and
passion you have and put it in one thing
that isn't a stable investment look at
crypto right
look
nothing right i'm not but then again
we've had this discussion before i'm not
an investor at all like it doesn't
excite me but
some people would have put everything
into that and it can bottom out and some
of my friends their their universe
circles around a black hole which is
their relationship right and their
relationship gobbles up everything and i
say look if that relationship doesn't
work out you're left with nothing
because you put your whole life into
that same football teams and some people
probably get depressed when their team
gets relegated but this is why
again i love martial arts and there was
a black belt i saw a speech that he made
when he got his black belt and he said
you know
i'll lose friends i'll lose family
my job my money all of these things can
be taken away from me but jiu jitsu can
never be taken away from me like the
camaraderie the brotherhood the
accomplishments he's like
he held his black belt he was like
wherever i go in the world whatever
happens to me i still have this and i
was like that's
that's really
compelling it was pretty emotional to
hear it as well
what do you think that that symbolizes
what does him holding up a black belt
symbolize
i quite like the fact that it's a
you're
you're almost stuck in a
tenure of never-ending development
within a specific field but not just the
field of philosophy that you can do on
your own or something where you can read
books and become ryan holiday and become
the expert of the stoics with jujitsu
it's
it's something you can't do on your own
you could have the best gym the best
black belt but if he's in a room on his
own he can't do the sport there's
camaraderie there's brotherhood there's
teaching people there's educating people
there's being a mentor to people there's
being an inspiring
you know figure to people there's
this massive hierarchy you know if you
look at like the military
you've had generals and captains and you
know all of this lieutenants and
sergeants
i believe men crave this hierarchy
between them where you know tribes for
hundreds of thousands of years you've
earned your stripes
and now you can have that in a martial
arts setting where people are safe they
don't have to go to war they don't have
to leave their families for periods of
time
it's nice to go in and know who's above
you know who's below you know who you
can give advice to and who you can go to
for advice
and it's a very powerful
feeling to know that and
it's a bizarre experience almost where
i'll take my martial arts gear with me
somewhere across the world and when i
put on my belt i have respect from
someone without ever even talking to
them and it it's something whenever you
interview anyone that does jujitsu they
always have that little spark that
little this person is going to fight me
but he's also going to care about me
he's also got respect for the work i've
been i've got the respect for him and i
think there are a lot of little
parts of the human psych
that jujitsu caters for which
modern day society doesn't
what is one of the problems that in
jiu-jitsu your status that you achieve
is directly proportional to the amount
of work that you put in i know you can
go to um shitty gyms where maybe you'll
be given a purple belt before you
perhaps should be and then that's a less
respected gym or whatever when you go
and train globally and there's certainly
harder gyms as well right or ones that
are seen with more prestige but
generally
your work put in is
directly related to the belt that you
carry around your waist so what you're
what you're showing with the belt isn't
the belt what you're showing with the
belt is all of the years that you've
spent doing it one of the problems that
you have at the moment with regards to
fame is that fame has become decoupled
from things that used to be worthy of
making people famous so our mutual
friend adam collards just gone on love
island for the second time and love
island is basically the hunger games for
fame you get picked out of obscurity you
get thrown at the top of a pile you come
out with a million dollar million pounds
pretty little thing contract and like
several million instagram followers and
there you are that's the next five years
of your life well you're the same person
that you were six weeks ago
whitney 21 year old hairdresser from
[ __ ] bristol or whatever you are like
nothing has changed so what people have
done now is they've seen the fact that
obligation free status is available you
can just hope to be plucked out of
obscurity remember that guy on tick tock
who was skateboarding down the street
drinking was it cranberry juice and
listening to a particular song and the
song went to number one and now he's got
this very different sort of life because
he was skateboarding down the street
drinking cranberry juice when someone's
ability or when society begins to reward
with fame actions that don't deserve it
people are going to immediately think
that the way to get fame is no longer to
do the hard things consistently over a
long period of time at very high quality
what they're going to see is i need to
be in the right place at the right time
and hope that i get plucked out of
obscurity and thrown at the top of the
tree
it's a one of the last remaining true
meritocracies where i think i've got
that word right have i you're yeah thank
god for that um
and it's it's great that nothing's going
to influence that and i really enjoy the
fact that i started jiu jitsu before i
had a blue tick before i had a book deal
before i had [ __ ] anything notable
and nothing's changed and i love that
it doesn't matter who i am i still line
up in belt order we still wipe the mats
together you know the only time that i
ever try and assert status is when it's
time to clean the mats and i'm there i'm
like listen mate i don't know your name
but that's not how you wipe the mats
i've had ringworm twice this year and
you don't know what it's like having a
girlfriend and ringworm where you can't
touch them you're laying in bed you get
a bit of skin skin i'm like get off me
i've got ringworm so it's uh it's one of
those times where it's really truly an
amazing thing to go in and
another thing as well is that you can
access some of the best athletes in the
world so when i came to austin last time
i saw you i'm still recovering from that
hangover i was training literally with
the david beckham's the cristiano
ronaldos of the world and i went into
the gym i had to do like a little form
and our mutual friend zach
was like tell under i went to his gym
and he's like bro come correct man you
gotta come to my gym i was like yeah
sweet so i'd already trained in the
morning i'd go there for lunch and uh
it was war
and some of the guys in there i said oh
my gosh attacker brothers they're sick
and i'm like oh my god there's that cody
steel i was like he's sick
and um
even their culture was very different to
where i've been before but they were
super welcoming none of them knew what i
did for work no one really gave a [ __ ]
they were very respectful when we rolled
they actually all of them lowered their
level to me so we could have fun roles
they could have smashed me they could
have wiped the floor with me but instead
smile on the face most of them didn't
even have their gum shields in and it
was such a like a a great opportunity to
train with some of the best i'm
intimidated right i can talk in front of
thousands of people that's fine doing a
ted talk no sweat patches training with
these guys i was like oh my god you know
and i think that's one of the things as
well that i love about the sport
i put a clip up a couple of weeks ago
about a feminist called louise perry
explaining that while some girls think
that choking is a passionate sign of
love uh others are misinterpreting it
and it's not actually that and that
girls should stop showing their bruises
on tick tock as a badge of honor what
were your thoughts there
yeah i commented on this i don't think
one woman can objectively hold an
opinion for all women same way that you
know that that's not allowed
irrespective of genders no one can say
this is my opinion on something
therefore it's all of your opinions i
didn't like the objective manner in
which you said that
i do think that you know any bruises on
the neck between genders it's probably a
telltale sign that you're being a bit
too rough you know it's probably what a
bruise is i don't ever advocate any
striking or violence between people
but i think that she'd probably be
better off doing a survey monkey and
asking women of the world a good large
population
why it is they may like choking and i
mean it's not women that just like
choking i think if you look at
asphyxiation deaths there's a lot of men
in there as well and um yeah do you know
what
it it's crazy that
straight away when you use the word
feminist it puts everyone on edge
including women because
what was a true passion
and passion at science and i'm sure
feminists over across history have done
some really stellar things for women
but there's now this kind of extremist
group of people that are trying to
they're almost like liberals in a sense
they want to rewrite everything they
want everything to change and straight
away as soon as you said i had a
feminist on the podcast people oh god
here we go what's coming next and um
it's annoying like
this isn't just in this context for
someone labels me labels me a misogynist
which they probably have already
veganism
10 15 years ago i'd be like fair play do
you know what fair play i love animals
too but the fact that you don't eat them
i love that then the extremists come
along and someone goes oh i had a vegan
on the part oh [ __ ] there we go you
know what i mean so
it's it's one of those things where i
also appreciate that your podcast is
really doing well and for some guests
that could just be their moment in the
limelight they knew that was going to be
a clip they knew there would be some
controversy and they could then
link arms with other extremist feminists
but although i think people should 100
remain safe everything should have
consent everything each person to their
own i mean you can't sit there and go
strangling is really bad oh don david a
wine bottle up his ass what about that
you know like so it is one of those
things i think they should ask women
there's a lot of women in your comments
as well they're like no yeah that's
exactly not why
with louise uh her stance in particular
is an interesting one because she
considers him herself a feminist but on
the other side of that she's not a sex
positive feminist so she doesn't think
that sex work is the same as normal work
she doesn't think that only fans should
be normalized she doesn't think that the
highest calling that women should go for
always is their careers and to call
yourself a feminist in most young
people's circles at the moment would be
someone that would be for all of those
things whereas louise i think would be
more of a trad feminist like she'd be
accused of being like a trad wife or
something even though she writes for the
spectator which is like does she write
for the spectator no she doesn't she
writes the new statesman which is very
much on the left and she also has a
organization which helps to
prosecute women who have been killed
when men use the excuse of rough sex
as a difference
um so i mean
one thing to note about this is that if
people decide to comment on a particular
clip that's taken from an episode and i
say did you watch the full episode
because
evidently this is a clip which is taken
from it no i don't need to and it's like
okay well i mean you're not you're not
taking this particularly seriously so
why why should i um i think that one of
the points that she makes is quite
interesting though which is that girls
on tick tock is showing off bruises as a
badge of honor that they're saying look
this is how passionate my love is this
is how important he finds my
attractiveness
that is a very impressionable group of
young girls that are being told that
this is something that they should
strive for and one of the concerns is
that almost any guy will do what almost
any girl tells him to do to her because
guys are terrified about their
performance and just want to do it right
whatever it is they just want to do it
right whereas the reverse isn't
necessarily true i mean i would be
interested to know how many girls would
say yes to choking their male partner if
their male partner said i'm absolutely
certain it would be fewer and it may be
quite a few fewer i just think that
it is an important time especially with
tick tock and how messed up and how much
social anxiety there is and how much
vulnerability there is amongst gen z
kids
i mean there's girls that show off
self-harm marks on there there's girls
that give tips about anorex anorexia and
stuff on that like it seems to me like
fair play for doing successfully on the
platform but for a very young group it
seems
pretty dangerous i i don't think from
the outside looking in it looks like a
particularly positive environment to be
in if you were a
14 year old guy or girl
it's interesting i'll start on the the
only fancy thing is something that i've
been thinking about for quite a while
and again i'm starting
but i actually i i can understand both
sides of the argument where she's saying
like look don't sell naked pictures
yourself on the internet especially i
think and i'm pretty sure if people buy
it they then own the image or there's
something crazy like that i could be
wrong however i actually quite like the
idea of women being able to perform
these paid services without having to be
in the room with another man or being in
a strip club with drunk men and or being
in a position where they're unsafe they
could do it remotely from a room with a
camera so i actually quite like the
division between
the woman and the man i think that's a
lot safer and i think that you know if
you were to say to a woman you can make
300 a night in a strip club but you've
got to you know dance on drunk men or
whatever or you can make 150 a day and
you could just take pictures in your
underwear and do you know whatever for
guys i quite like that safety barrier
between them uh because i i although you
said people people criticize sex work
although i'm not an advocate of it
personally
it's one of the oldest professions i
think that's ever existed
then but i mean just to inject that
would you say that that's empowering
women like it it seems odd to me that
female empowerment has gone from
wanting women and men to be treated as
equals
to encouraging women to get naked for
the price of a cheeseburger like that to
me doesn't seem like the peak of female
empowerment and neither does telling
women that the most important thing that
they'll ever do in their lives is their
career and i think that the trickle-down
effect of that is that one of the
easiest ways or one of the potentially
easiest ways to either supplement your
income or increase your income is
to do something like this on the side as
you say it's one of the oldest
industries in existence it's probably
what the first transactions were made
for either sex or food you know like
survival and reproduction it was a spear
it was a piece of grain or it was
a girl and
i'm not convinced that that is a
progressive idea uh that's not for me to
say that girls that would potentially go
and do sex work elsewhere in strip clubs
is it safer yeah absolutely would i
prefer a girl to be uh working on cams
instead of walking the streets yeah
absolutely my concern is that the
frictionlessness and the fact that it's
seen as a no
externality no negative externality
option for a lot of women to do is that
it's lowered the ick floor for a lot of
girls to get into an industry where
they're not going to make that much
money they are potentially going to lock
themselves into being a type of girl
maybe photos get leaked maybe a future
employer or boyfriend sees them like
here's a question would you be happy
getting into a very long-term
relationship with a girl who
recently quit only fans or currently
still had one
oh my god that's such a misogynistic
question no i'm joking like um it's
interesting because
if i was to this is the defense i like
to say a lot i really wouldn't want my
future daughter to do it right that's
that's fine that that can give me a
stance currently as a potential student
i could be a father in two years or
whatever
there's another there's another point to
that you say about the empowerment i
have no idea because you know the
empowerment side of things i have no
idea what that's like but there is kind
of one other
avenue for
kind of thinking on this
there's a lot of potentially low status
men that we talk about maybe utility of
deprivation is one of my favorite jordan
peterson topics where he talks about you
know masturbating giving yourself access
to
so many women can negate your actions
are imperative to improve the quality of
your life if you're wanking every day to
porn or to own your fans you're hardly
going to feel g'ed up to ask the girl in
a coffee shop if she wants to go for a
date
but
i can only imagine how many sick and
twisted [ __ ] men out there are
sperving on women's instagram
and oh she's so fit oh she's so fit
whatever
i quite like the idea sometimes that
some of these absolute sickos can
actually then access naked pictures of
that person
and fulfill their fantasies online
a long way away
we're opposed to potential other things
that they might do
stalking that person
becoming fanatically obsessed with this
person or whatever those things are so
in my recent thinking recently i was
like i hope i don't know i hope that
this market is catering to some sick men
one of the problems one of the problems
you have is there's been a bunch of only
fans models that have been killed by
fans that they've had so i would say
that the degree of separation that you
have on instagram which is evidently not
for you you feel absolutely no
obligation or sense of ownership or
sense of contribution or intimacy with
that person
anybody that's got 10 bucks can become
one of like have the virtual boyfriend
service or whatever that's not the same
with a follow nobody expects that with a
follow on instagram i think that you're
actually
from a psychological perspective for men
i think that you're leaning them further
into a dangerous arena as opposed to
taking them away from it
that's actually a very valid point which
i hadn't thought about these are all
just
thinking is my mind sometimes i'll be
like i'll be walking somewhere and my
mind will just drift off and i'll try
and break down things like this that's
another valid point because those kind
of interactions are usually exclusively
only to people in relationships and
when you're financially incentivized and
sometimes financially propped up by the
income that you get from this group of
men you can become subservient to them
and then if you discontinue that
subservient nature it could be met with
animosity a lot of revenge yeah
i think that it's a really delicate one
because the psychology of of you know
men like that jordan peterson clip where
he goes a man can expose himself to more
naked women in an hour than previously a
man would ever have seen an entire
lifetime and the psychological
implications of that
are
profound and
probably not fully
you know appreciated or studied or
understood well there was an interesting
point in a podcast i did with andre
huberman recently where he said that
men specifically who train themselves to
get aroused by watching other people
have sex
may not have the arousal response carry
over when it comes to being in reality
with a normal person so you could
neurologically train yourself to become
avoider
in a way if that's what you get used to
if you condition yourself to become
aroused by watching other people and you
then get one-on-one
that might not work
it may not work in the way that you're
supposed to so you have increases in
erectile dysfunction amongst men a lot
of the time because they've desensitized
themselves they've down regulated their
arousal response so much by watching
ever increasingly extreme or exciting
porn and then reality just can't compete
you know that's actually such an
interesting topic i know we're talking
about
so much porn now
um what's it called when
men like to watch someone else sleep
with their wife
so it would be cuckold pawn i think
crocodile yeah so i've always wondered
how someone ends up in that position and
you might have just opened a can of
worms there where like you say if you're
a third party watching other people have
sex and you are in love with your wife
and you want the best thing for her then
the cockhold experience may come from
that and again there's that genre of
pawn in the pov point of view to maybe
try and negate that but one thing that
i'm genuinely con look yeah concerned
about all right and this is nothing the
metaverse right i never gave it like
real much thought but i digest things
over and over and we both have a mutual
friend luke he went to a red bull
experience where they go to six
festivals in half an hour wearing an
oculus and they're sat down
but in the metaverse they get handed a
drink which is actually made in front of
them but as they drink the drink the
oculus notes that they look up when they
look down there another festival
and i was like wow that's that's pretty
[ __ ] amazing
and then i saw a story about a guy who
watches movies in the metaverse because
you can watch a movie on innocuous but
he actually watches it from a penthouse
apartment in bed in las vegas where
that's not where he lives but in his
oculus he is so he's like why would i
not wear this i'm in a shitty [ __ ]
one bed in the middle of america when i
can put this on and be in a penthouse in
vegas
and then i was thinking about
let's say we get neuralink right in the
next few years we could tap into you
know telling our body something
why would you risk
stds pregnancy all of these things when
you could have a virtual experience of
having sex and people are going to be
very quick to scoff at that but
i was thinking to myself the other day
okay let's say in three years time
i can put on an oculus and see my
favorite dj play at clustenbury and
instead of
paying the money driving to glastonbury
parking camping queuing for toilets
being stuck in massive crowds idea of
getting trampoline losing phone
reception like festivals you give up a
lot to have a good time
imagine if me and three of my friends
can sit on the sofa
watch bicep play put an oculus on it
feels like we're in the crowd but
whenever we want to go for a toilet we
could just take the oculus off go use
our toilet we don't even have to leave
the house you know if we wanted to take
some mdma we can do it imagine as you
turn the oculus i can see my friend i
can even virtually high-five him
i was just joking about that but as i
was saying i was like that sounds pretty
[ __ ] appealing
going to the pub with your mates why
would we pay for for real beer when we
can buy a pack and have it at home and
we can have a virtual you know banter
like pointing at your mates and you know
we're soon very slippery on the slopes
of everyone goes yeah but i love leaving
the house
but would you if there was a better
alternative without having to have you
ever seen the bruce willis film
surrogates
you remember that one
yes um
i've seen it i'm trying to think i keep
getting it mixed up with the jumper one
no not that so it's basically what
you're talking about so in the future
people have surrogates they're these
sort of avatar perfect versions of them
and you buy upgrades for your surrogate
and it walks around in the real world
and you just sit in your apartment in a
leather chair basically
locked in and controlling it in one way
or another and then bruce decides he
wants to do something different dude i i
really am
pretty concerned i think about that i
mean i get comments sometimes on the
more black pilly conversations that have
come up on this channel from guys who
have evidently lost hope that the
future's going to be better for them in
terms of dating and is saying uh don't
worry boys just hold on the sex robots
are coming that's not ironic they're not
saying that in an ironic way they're
saying right now i feel like i'm so
invisible to the other sex that all i'm
the only piece of hope that i have is
technology coming in and saving me from
the current world like
that's a terrifying situation to think
that we've managed to get a super
affluent super comfortable society to
that that's the
pinnacle that most guys or many guys
should i say not most at all but a
significant minority of guys think is
there outlet
yeah i've spoken about this uh quite a
lot in my most recent book which i've
got to credit you for i'll talk about in
a second some of the uh parts of the
book that are quite literally from our
conversations but um there's two kind of
things here one the pandemic really
[ __ ] slingshotted people into the
online dating world because they they
physically would break the law to go on
a physical date the organic
meets that you know meeting someone in a
coffee shop someone at your local gym
whatever it is all those were taken away
so people went to online pretty
aggressively and
it's fear of rejection you know now you
don't have to get rejected you know
before you'd have to interview for 10
jobs now your cv gets rejected on
linkedin before you even get there but
the world is becoming more and more
comfortable we don't have to have
awkward conversations anymore so you
have that and there's also a phenomena
which i write about called declinism
where people have a tendency to think
things are getting worse you know and
again jordan peterson was in a debate a
good few years ago where someone was
talking about climate change this this
what's your thing on this and he goes
do you think you have an easier life
than your grandparents
and the woman wouldn't answer it you
know
everyone's so caught up about how bad
things are that he was like do you
reckon you have a you know better life
yeah you know let me just give you
something there man so there's a concept
called the tocqueville paradox so as the
living standards in the society rise
people's expectations rise along with
them but obviously your expectations are
able to move much more quickly than
reality can so after a while most of the
low-hanging fruit that reality can
deliver to you in terms of convenience
and comfort and such like that they
start to level off however your
expectations continue to go up so what
you end up with is a delta between where
you see life being and what you thought
life was supposed to be
that's the tockville paradox the fact
that as living standards rise so do
expectations and then expectations
overtake the reality
and that causes people to be
dissatisfied i think that's very close
to the um
concept yeah
and people seem to think you know
i think that a lot of people even
thinking about having children you know
we've got a population crisis nearing
around the corner you had a fantastic
interview with jordan peterson about
that 50 years in the united states has
been since people have been producing
enough kids to have younger generations
so not only are we going to that i think
there is a bit of in the subconscious
people going why would i want to bring a
child into this world but there's a book
called factfulness
forgive me for how's yours thank [ __ ]
for that
and that was pretty pandemic that i read
that but still so much of that rings
true there's one part in the book where
he's like
four million babies will die before
their first birthday and you're like oh
it's terrible down from 12 million five
years ago
the way the media like portray
everything you do feel like the world's
getting worse but the world is getting
better and i do like to remind people of
that and it is tragic that declinism is
having such a profound impact on
people's thinking where they they do
suddenly like pessimism bias loss
aversion we're all genetically
programmed to negative outcomes and we
have that with the future as well which
is which is tragic i whenever i get like
a in a deep conversation about this my
friends i'm like guys elon will save us
elon will save us he's not [ __ ]
buying twitter anymore he's about to be
sued by twitter do you see that he's
just been the lawsuit's just been
unveiled about him what else can they do
because in essence he's lifted the skirt
on some [ __ ] that's been going on
with twitter he's aired the laundry for
the world to see i think it's [ __ ]
brilliant and you know
there's so much skullduggery that's been
going on in the social media space and
there's so much of even twitter's code
that definitely got reversed during that
process when like joe rogan and all
these people got hundreds of thousands
or tens of thousands of followers
overnight where they've obviously been
shadow banning people the political
leaning stuff you know
and it it's very hard to ignore the fact
that
many of these social media platforms are
switchboards to political leanings and
and narratives and made you know when i
went home to spend some time my parents
recently i realized that my parents
spent a lot of the time in the pandemic
locked in lockdown and it has changed
them and
all they had was each other the news
the newspaper
and i've now realized that my parents
cannot have a debate or a discussion
anymore because they are so
set it's almost like
the fabric of your stance sets in stone
after about two years so my mom and dad
really don't like elon musk and i was
like i was trying to figure out why my
dad was like oh you know
it doesn't pay enough tax or any of
these things
and then i was like right let's see if i
can have like a genuine discussion i was
like the atrocities going on in ukraine
terrible i go i said to my dad because
for 30 years i've gone to my dad for dad
what's communism dad why is this
happening dad what what does social
estates mean
and i said dad
why is putin invaded in ukraine and he's
like because he's evil
and i was like i think there's there's
some
bigger reasons to that and i was like
what about nato nato being pray my dad's
like no he's just evil and i was like i
think that's a narrative that's been
painted online i couldn't get anything
else out of him i had another discussion
recently where
there was a
uh
someone on lex friedman's podcast who
was talking about how the nazis were the
first to stop pregnant women from having
x-rays
and the nazis were some of the first
people to stop their nation smoking
30 years after the nazis stopped their
nation smoking america publicly said
this is probably about the 60s i think
or 70s if we found out that smoking
hindered people's health would make it
illegal
and
when i said that once i said oh did you
know the nazis were actually at the
forefront of of health of their own
people people go how the [ __ ] can you
can you sit there and say that i'm not
supporting anything they've done and
suddenly i was getting abused from
someone for bringing up the fact that
the nazis were a little bit further
ahead in that medical field and i was
like wow i actually think in recent
years we've moved away from the ability
to even have
discussions on so many topics anymore
and especially with things like twitter
and all of these things have you found
that
it would short form
especially people that maybe
you and i right now podcasting it's a
channel that's not governed by media by
the big media although it is a source of
media i feel like these are some of the
only genuine conversations that can be
had i feel like podcasts are now the
back channels where you can actually say
and talk about things
i would agree i think one of the main um
common denominator between all of the
situations you've spoken about there is
that people have attached their sense of
self-worth and or identity
to
a position that they hold
that if they were to let go of their
position it would be the same as
destruction so eckhart tolle talks about
this the fact that when you're having a
discussion with people
a lot of the time the reason that they
don't want to admit that they're wrong
is it's tantamount to ego destruction
right that this would feel like the
complete removal of everything that i am
because if i'm wrong about that what
else might i be wrong about and
there are certain people out there that
are more curious than others and they'll
be the ones that will be able to
continue to update their software and
their programming as new information
comes in
personally for me i spent almost all of
my time especially now i'm in austin
because it's a very open uh
philosophically open city i spend almost
all of my time having conversations that
i don't know the answer to and asking
other smart people if they've got an
answer to it so for me i haven't really
noticed that but certainly online
comments are reactionary they're short
they take the worst possible uh
implication of of what someone's words
could mean and i don't know that that
just doesn't seem like
for the people that decide to do it very
quickly they're going to realize that
it's not an effective way to exist now
that's going to mean that they're
miserable they're going to be uh their
negativity bias is going to be even
worse
so yeah i mean
i choose to not ever associate myself
with those people i want to have
conversations about stuff as freely as i
can now one of the things that i have
started to realize is that there's a
limit to what i can even talk about on
podcasts there are conversations that i
sometimes refrain from having or at
least i have to force myself to have
with friends because most of the
conversations that i have are on
podcasts and that means that when i want
to really push the boundaries of
something that's different or
interesting or like can we talk about
whatever topic that would be completely
unacceptable even on something like
youtube
that's something that i've conditioned
myself into so when you think about if
most of your conversations were you and
the media i'm aware it's like a one-way
conversation but if most of your
conversations were between you and the
guardian or the bbc or cnn or fox news
or whatever
that is going to become your sense of
identity i've internalized one as well
it's just that my internalization is uh
like guard rails on what i can speak
about somebody else's are the guard
rails have been set on them by a media
organization
yeah it's interesting i think that one
of the most worrisome things that i see
is the disintegration of ignorance where
ignorance is now painted in such a bad
light where even when we spoke about the
only found thing before i expressed my
point of view and you're like well
actually this is what's happening and
then i'm like oh i'm actually wrong on
that point which is fantastic because
you know i i appreciate that and the
same thing with like you know
trying to have a discussion with my dad
why is putin doing that and i think that
it's annoying that someone could go well
actually this this this happened you
shouldn't even be question i have
ignorance about the whole situation
there but the thing is you can't really
easily find out what's going on you know
if i if you were to ask the majority of
the people in the uk
why is this happening they'd struggle to
give you an answer on it and i feel that
this is crazy right i've i've become
more
concerned with history as i'm getting
older
and people used to tell me history was
such an amazing subject i was like
medicine through time get out of here
but now i'm getting a little bit older
mate i spend a lot of time on youtube i
went down a north korea rabbit hole the
other day i reckon i watched about five
hours of documentaries about north korea
why
fascination
like we just get told like are they evil
which i i agree with but i didn't really
understand what was going on there you
know we um joe rogan had
uh
park in i don't get a name beyond me
part and i was listening to that i was
mortified i was like the whole world
needs to know about this we should have
been taught this in secondary school why
was i learning about medicine through
time in you know like in america i
really like became fascinated about all
these things and
it
as time goes on it it's one of those
things you get you get concerned about
why are we learning the things we're
learning why aren't we learning about
what's happening and so much of history
does repeat itself and i think it's
absolutely bonkers that
we don't have like better narratives on
that at the moment
so there's a concept called fire hosing
which i learned from a friend
gwinderbogle he said with so many
competing narratives in the digital age
disinformation agents can't convince you
of any single narrative so instead they
overwhelm you with many contradictory
narratives and still you start to doubt
everything and become confused
demoralized and passive
so the point there is that it is
significantly easier to confuse and
demoralize people than it is to convince
them of anything
and fire hosing involves throwing all of
the information at you until you can't
work out what's true anymore i think
that's what you're seeing
it sounds almost slightly zygotic
do you want to talk about trying to talk
about the cool stuff you put in your new
book
yeah so when we were sat in austin
sinking some beers
you know i never let good advice fall on
deaf ears i put that in both my books so
far
um so the zygarnic effect which you told
me about about waiters remembering open
bills and forgetting about them when
they're closed
you started then telling me about the
implications that could have to our to
our psyche and writing about it really
expanded that
where i've actually experienced this
firsthand like
when you see someone or someone very
attractive and everything in you goes oh
my god i found this person really
attractive i'd love to ask for their
number you're on the tube or it might be
someone you know i remember doing a
qualification once and it was a five-day
course and the first day i really found
this girl attractive it was the last 10
minutes on the last day i was like 19
that i asked her oh can i have your
number she goes i thought you'd never
ask and we ended up going on some like
amazing days it was like incredible
i i think about today if i hadn't have
asked how long would i have thought
about that what are the mental
implications of not doing things you
know that job that you saw on linkedin
that you didn't apply for and now you're
following the guy that's in the role and
he's loving his life just got a big
bonus like all of these things take up
mental taxes and
i keep thinking about loops tv adverts
oh after the break we've got seven ways
to kill zombies in apocalypse you're
like oh my god
the loop's been opened shut shutting
loops and i've i've really coined that
into like a bit of a motivator in uh how
to be confident but like there was that
the pyrrhic victories as well which you
spoke about like a dog leaping off a
cliff to bite a bird for dinner yeah
tons amount to defeat yeah how many how
many things are truly pyric in daily
life that scare us
very few i think like most of the time
what people are doing is they're slowly
uh chewing away they're eating away at
their own sense of sovereignty with
stuff like that i think i spoke to you
about the anxiety cost as well right
like the um amount of mental effort that
it takes to consider something that you
could get rid of by simply doing the
thing all of the stuff that you leave
undone all of the loops all of the
uncompleted tasks all of pretty much
everything that you decide isn't yet
finished that you could have just done
right now if you were to have just done
it right now that would have been sorted
yes as it's one of those things where
yeah i've read those out i'm recording
the audio book at the moment so i'm back
in the studio in about you finished it
bloody hell look are you happy
printed on friday uh doing the audiobook
it takes i read for about three hours a
day for five days
and
it is pretty heavy but then
you it's your book so some chapters i
wrote more recently than others but
sometimes you don't realize how long the
sentence is so
you have to go through then you have
sense then you have words that you've
potentially misinterpreted then uh
breathing is difficult as well because
you've got to learn how to breathe
properly and when to breathe and some
sentences you might have to do 15 words
before a comma so you have to take mini
breaths in between it's a bit of an art
form recorded in audiobook i would agree
but uh a credit to douglas murray his
book is war in the west is about
11 12 hours
incredible how and
i i i might be doing a podcast with uh
doug's marriage in the next few months
his voice
i love it right
wait
he's got this this posh
yeah authoritative
voice that and he's like
well
that's very interesting
and i'm like
yes it is
and i i think uh but when i saw that 12
hours i was like my book's probably
going to be six seven hours i was like
wow that is some stint of recording an
audiobook it took him an entire week as
well but i think he does it in he does
it in morning and afternoon stint it was
happening he was recording it as i was
in new york with him so i left and that
first day after i left uh he was going
something that i saw on an episode of
seth stevens davidowitz who is a data
scientist
and it links to what you're talking
about earlier on about comfort he says
we sometimes mistake a comfortable
activity for an enjoyable activity and
this rounds up something i've been
thinking about for probably about three
years which is that
a lot of the time when you consider how
future you would have wanted you to
spend your time right now it involves
doing something enjoyable but current
you wants you to do something which is
comfortable so it would be the
difference between going out to a salsa
class for the first time ever which
might be [ __ ] but might be absolutely
brilliant and even if it is [ __ ] you're
going to remember it a lot more than you
are yet another night watching the
terminal list on amazon prime or
whatever
but because we optimize for comfort in
the moment and we presume that comfort
in the moment will be enjoyment in the
long term
you often end up
selecting for
comfort and ease and convenience and
over a long period of time that ends up
with just a pretty dissatisfacting
unsatisfactory life and that's kind of
the same as what you're talking about in
terms of you need to have something
which will motivate yourself like what
is the little thing that you rely on
that when you think about it look i
probably just need to go and do this
thing because it's going to be quicker
for me to work out whether or not i
should have done it by doing it than it
is for me to just think about it all the
time and obsess
yeah i think that you can measure your
growth by measuring your discomfort uh
so right now i'm i'll put this in the
book as well
how how many things this week truly make
you uncomfortable how many things this
week truly make you a bit nervous and
put you on edge if there's a
considerable amount you're probably in a
growth phase and if there's nothing
you're probably in a stagnation phase
and i'm quick to
spot these the last few weeks i was like
oh it's good to be back in australia
life's good so i was like [ __ ]
i'm going to compete in jiu jitsu this
weekend on sunday so on sunday i'm going
to drive an hour and a half away to
fight other men in my division at my
weight level why because quite frankly
it scares the [ __ ] out of me training is
comfortable and it's not even the fight
that i'm scared of it's the expectations
in which i attach to it and
that
that
leading up to doing
unenjoyable finishing whether i win or
lose
in hindsight it's amazing like
winning is great but losing
i love to remind myself how amazing it
is to lose because there's no better
reality check or dose of inspiration
that you can get
than having your
ego realigned to reality and i think
that's such a rewarding thing and like
let's even say this
say you reach out for a podcast guest
who you think is probably a few echelons
above where you're currently at and they
reject you that's one of the best things
that can happen because
if you've made it this far that's just
gonna put fire in your belly and you're
gonna go okay i'm gonna grow this
[ __ ] until the point you're
knocking on my door to come and do this
and i think people have also not only
do they avoid uncomfortable situations
they can't quite see the potential
upside of putting themselves in it and
even better yet they're so fearful of
losing when that could be
the key thing uh lucy lord my friend she
says the lessons you need are in the
tasks you're avoiding
that's very nice
she might have got it from someone else
but that's right fair play give it to
lucy it's okay yeah that's that's lovely
man i i i don't disagree i think that
most people understand the places that
they're hiding away from themselves and
you're quite right it's
the things that you don't want to look
at other things that you don't want to
do
and those are the identifiers
uh
what else what else about the new book
you excited for we'll probably we'll
have another conversation i'm sure once
it's out but is there anything else that
you're super excited about it
like it's it people think it's a book
book about confidence like i'm like hey
my name is james smith i'm so confident
let me teach you how i've done it and
weirdly my life is something that i look
back on i'm quite proud of a younger
version of me because he wasn't as
intelligent he just happened to make the
right decisions and i look back now and
i'm thinking [ __ ] you did all right
there mate you did all right there but
i've come to realize that confidence
isn't so much about success it's about
failure and it's about how you deal and
how you
how you react to failure and i think
that people
they see the spectrum from the wrong end
they see it at the success end oh you're
confident because you're successful i'm
like well i'm actually confident because
losing doesn't phase me things going
wrong doesn't phase me why
because that's not the metric that you
should be setting for success
imagine this and this is again something
i've written in the book
why does something going right have to
be successful why can't you trying to do
something be successful
you know let's say that i love using the
setting of dating where
people are so worried to ask for
someone's number and for it to go wrong
but
if you were to break that down into like
a three-minute segment the second you
have put yourself into that position
asked before they even have the chance
to compute in response you could win
that's your win
and if people realize that even if just
sending their cv to someone a potential
employer that can be your win
it doesn't have to be getting the job
and if you can set these again i've been
doing this before weight loss for years
i wouldn't lose 10 pounds i'm like how
about losing one pound and making that a
win and if people can get better at what
their wins look like and where they're
setting the objectives and how that
failure you're only going to ever add
strings to your bow by failing and the
thing that if people can get that in
their head it's more about a book about
dealing with failure than it is a book
about being confident and if you were to
think of the most
the confident person in your mind the
most confident person you've ever met
when something goes wrong how much do
they take it to heart
very little and it's kind
and it's it's that kind of mindset i
want people to get into it's not easy
but it's certainly worth it if people
persevere with it enough one of my
favorite bits from the live tour that i
went to go and see you do the most
recent one in newcastle was how you were
explaining to people if they don't enjoy
their job that you're basically risking
nothing to then move on to go and do
something else can you just go through
that
so
firstly i like to remind people that
so many of them are doing really well in
a job they don't enjoy
that's just the fact most people in
recruitment right there are probably a
very few amount of people in recruitment
that actually enjoy it i've done it
myself
but they're good at it and they are you
know i i've always wanted to have my own
job and my own business but
you know i just don't know you know i
can't afford for things not to go right
i've got kids you know i've just got a
mortgage on a house and i'm like cool
okay but here's something to consider
you're doing very well in a job you're
not passionate about
so if you're selling people to jobs
you're not interested in
do you have the capabilities to sell
something you actually give a [ __ ] about
probably
now what if that doesn't work out well
you probably go back to a job in
recruitment you're exactly where you
started and i think the people when they
really understand if they're dominating
something they don't like
the potential they have for dominating
something they do like is massive
and
again
i'm pretty sure it's a
statistic where people say when you ask
people on their deathbed
the thing they regret the most is the
things they didn't do not the things
that didn't work out
and
i wish people could have more
conversations with old people the old
people aren't like oh i went for it was
the worst decision ever they were
talking about things they didn't do and
i think that's really important
that people appreciate that your work
life is such a big constituent of your
overall life
and it gives you purpose it gives you
meaning it is a pillar of your mental
health it's so so important
and it kind of kills me that people
don't see the implications that has to
the rest of their lives because if you
don't enjoy your work life that is going
to affect your relationships it's going
to affect your training it's going to
affect your diet because we need to
you remember liking sims playing it back
in the day you got those little plus and
minus interactions
you want to be getting pluses from work
pluses from your partner and you don't
want anything in life to be giving you
those negative interactions because it
will take its time yeah man i mean
where you live what you do and who you
do with are the three most important
choices i think that you can make it's a
very
british
phenomenon i think
most of the american people that i've
spoken to and again this could be
selection effect from being in austin
which is full of cultural refugees from
elsewhere so that already people are
predisposed to travel but still i would
say that the uk seems to have a
disproportionate number of people who
are scared to take risks like that i
don't think that there is a healthy
number of role models that go and
move to australia or start start their
own business or drop a job or change
something in their life that they know
isn't working
in america you've got the american dream
right there's there's nothing like that
in the uk the uk is just a blueprint and
it's a blueprint to get by i think that
you know i'm i'm not sure about enough
of the history of the uk but people for
the large part probably just been
struggling to survive to get by there's
not been a dream if you're if you go to
the uk it's like okay go to school
go to college go to uni get a job hold
it down get a mortgage
have enough money to retire
and
what i could be completely wrong with
this i could be naive i hate it when
people talk about their 50s and 60s do
this now to your 50s and 60s i
appreciate there's a lot of sentiment to
that but now is very important too
your 20s to 30s are very important not
for your 50s and 60s they're important
for now
your 30s to 40s are very important not
for your 60s and 70s but for now
there's no point not making the most out
of now for a bid to have it later you
know there are so many people that hit
eject on life because they were too
long-sighted with that and i think that
i wish that there could be a better
culture in the uk to be like hey
do what you want
as long as you can pay bills you don't
get in debt as long as you don't you
know [ __ ] or lean on the [ __ ]
healthcare system the financial system
or bankrupt yourself then do whatever
the [ __ ] you want and ultimately i think
that people do need the rules to life to
be rewritten where it's more about
wake up do [ __ ] you enjoy
come home spend it with someone you
enjoy go to sleep get eight nine hours
and do it again rather than it being
like this it's kind of like rat race and
london
feels almost poisonous to me a little
bit i don't
really like the vibe of london and some
of my friends saying i'm absolutely
crazy for saying that
people like why do you like australia i
just i just like it better i i feel more
relaxed here i swim in the sea more i
really want to get a dog and just give
it a good life here in london i see so
many people just working so hard but i
don't see the happiness that should come
with that
i think the uk
is characterized by people who are
desperate to not lose rather than
desperate to win
no one cares about winning all that
they're bothered about is not losing
and that causes a
very
particular uncomfortable
scarcity mindset that is very hard to
get rid of
yeah 100 and i mean if anyone if anyone
in the uk is listening to this that
they're like oh i saw it for these two
you know you [ __ ] off abroad and
you're doing you're living your life it
if you're happy and you're listening to
this then [ __ ] you've completed it
well done you've you know you've scored
the highest score it's just there'll be
some young people listening to this and
they're like oh i don't know what to do
i i've just inherited some money or i've
got a bit of savings so i don't know
what to do
surely better to
go around the world experience different
cultures because
everyone in my family loves where they
live right my sister lives about five
minutes away from my parents my parents
live within the same 300 meters that
they were born they all went to the same
primary schools there was no reason ever
for me to not want to live there and i
all it took was for me to just go on a
bit of a whim i just had this urge to go
to australia i flew one way and i got
here and i was prepared to be completely
wrong i still am now and i just wish
that if anybody from the uk is listening
to this just go try out somewhere
different even if it means you know
working a job i actually did a tv piece
with an irish lady and i think she was
working for the bbc
and i was talking to her she goes oh you
still live in new york
and i go what'd you do she goes let's
work behind a bar in an irish bar in new
york and she's not working for the bbc
and she's not really enjoying her job
that much she goes it was the best time
in my life working in the irish bar i
said why'd you leave she goes my parents
pressured me to come home and get a
proper job and i was like oh
i kind of felt for them i was like you
did something to impress someone else
you did what the status quo said you
should have done and because of it in an
interview that should have been about my
first book we're now talking about you
not enjoying your life as much as you
did before
james smith ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you've got going on where should they go
tick-tock no joking
bring your breath
uh yeah online james smith pt anyway
they put it i'm i'm hoping for a rebrand
in a few years where i can just get the
the name at james smith that'd be
amazing who's got it
uh a pt
you're kidding me
now
mate i would love to there was one point
where he tried opening a business called
the academy and i sent him an email i
was like bro come on this doesn't look
good on you but um yeah hopefully
because that one day i am pt that is the
way i've come up and if i do experience
any more notable success in the future i
will always say that i'm a pt i've been
told by many people to tell people that
i'm an author because whenever i bump
into anyone in a business class like
what do you do i'm personal trainer
they're like all right
i think i'm some trust fund kid or
something but yeah um that would be good
anywhere they type in the name they
should find me they might find a vocal
singer called james smith as well just
look for the more handsome one and
you'll find me appreciate you james
cheers mate cheers mate thanks what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace